what's going on guys this is rob and the
living tribunal was spotted in the tv
spot for doctor strange too which has
everybody excited and it's the talk of
the town right we finally at least
they're teasing the appearance of the
tribunal we don't know if it'll actually
appear in any meaningful way if we'll
just get like a quick glimpse of it and
that'll basically be it in all honesty
given how dr strange 2 looks like it's
going to unfold it would be a perfect
chance to actually have the tribunal
step in to basically whisk doctor
strange and wanda to like the far shore
or the dimension of manifestations or
something like that which we'll talk
about here in a minute and basically put
him on trial right and just be like stop
what you're doing
i'm going to obliterate all of you your
earth and your universe which it could
do that'd be a great time to do that but
let's kind of wind the clock back a
little bit let's take a take a few steps
back and answer the burning questions
that pretty much all of you have what's
the living tribunal what's its purpose
and how powerful is it okay so here's
the thing if you guys are looking for
like a power hierarchy among all the
cosmic entities and really everybody who
exists in marvel comics i have that over
comics explained you'll find a link in
the description you can check that out
after this video but in terms of the
living tribunal let's kind of focus on
its powers first so
traditional or really conventional
wisdom says the living tribunal is this
infinitely powerful being and that's
true but not necessarily
for years and years and years that was
the case right for decades in marvel
comics the living tribunal was second
only to the one above all and with a few
exceptions like the molecule man owen
reese at his peak the original beyonder
from secret wars in 1984 at its peak
that precious few people were more
powerful than the living tribunal now
all this changed in the aftermath of
secret wars in 2015 one because the
living tribunal was killed by the
beyonders meaning there was no more
living tribunal that was followed up
with a story by jim starlin called
infinity revelations which basically had
adam warlock from an alternate reality
become the new living tribunal following
that you go into a comic called the
ultimates by a guy named al ewing this
team was
nuts they were ridiculously overpowered
right it was it was blue marvel adam
beshear who has yet to appear in the mcu
and we absolutely need him uh black
panther america chavez carol danvers
monica rambo spectrum i mean these are
all for the most part characters who
exist in the mcu in some capacity or
have existed outside of black panther
who of course chadwick boseman passed
away and blue marvel who we haven't seen
yet so like this stage is basically set
for like the ultimate avengers right so
it's only a matter of time fingers
crossed before we get them uh but during
alduing's ultimates what you got was
basically the living tribunal appearing
and essentially him establishing that
the living tribunal's power is relative
to the size and scope of the multiverse
because the multiverse was still
relatively new at the time the living
tribunal was not at its absolute peak of
power that's why the cosmic entities
master order and lord chaos were able to
merge into a singular being and then
destroy the living tribunal because it
was not at its peak of power uh if it
was at its peak of power it would have
been able to withstand that onslaught
and then would have annihilated or
recreated master order and lord chaos
that would have basically been it but
the long story short is that the living
tribunal is in effect the long arm of
the one above all that the one above all
is basically god in the entirety of
marvel comics that nothing is more
powerful than the one above all and that
the living tribunal exists to ensure the
will and the laws that have been laid
down by the one above all so that goes
into its purpose so originally in marvel
comics when the living tribunal first
appeared it was an old doctor strange
story from what is it strange tales uh
issue number
157 i think not going to swear to that i
could be wrong but basically this being
named zom had shown up now for look for
perspective here zom is way beyond
anybody in terms of magical power right
cathone sidorak doctor strange at his
peak the ancient one it doesn't matter
they all fall before the power of zom
and in fact he was so powerful the
living tribunal was the only one who
could defeat him and actually lock him
away so that dude's on a whole different
level if zom's ever brought into the mcu
and it's his marvel comic counterpart
that's how you know the mcu is basically
setting up to start winding down right
to literally start ending things him or
the beyonders or whatever those guys are
just on on a wholly different level of
power but regardless during this story
the living tribunal initially
established its role by telling stephen
strange that its job was to basically
ensure there was a balance of good or
good and evil in every single universe
and that earth itself was a more evil
place than it was good and so it was
going to destroy the earth ultimately
doctor strange proved that the earth
actually has the potential for good so
the living tribunal backed off and
walked away now years later that would
change and the reality here is that the
best description of the living
tribunal's purpose and role in marvel
comics came during the original infinity
gauntlet story when you basically had
thanos who gave the infinity gauntlet
and you got the cosmic congress and so
it was basically the cosmic entities of
the main marvel universe eternity
infinity master order lord chaos sire
hate mistress love all those guys they
basically came together and they asked
the living tribunal to step in and the
living tribunal
his response was basically no that's not
going to happen that thanos has the
infinity gauntlet but the infinity
stones are not outside of this universe
they are from the universe itself thanos
has simply attained a tool that was made
available to him or to anybody
in the universe therefore thanos with
the infinity gauntlet does not violate
any kind of multiversal law furthermore
if you eternity are not powerful enough
to keep yourself alive in the face of
thanos wielding the infinity gauntlet
then the weak make way for the strong
sorry about your luck and then he
basically took off now that goes into
the second part of the the living
tribunal's role which really over the
years has kind of turned into basically
managing and safeguarding the mystical
balances of the multiverse so in effect
in every one universe assuming the
marvel cinematic universe is like this
you can't have two doctor strangers in
the same universe that would be a
mystical imbalance you can't have two
sorcerers supremes like that it's why
the ancient one had to die and then
steven strange became the
sorcerer supreme it's why during the
events of spider-man no way home
presumably wong became the new sorcerer
supreme in the absence of steven strange
and then when stephen strange had
basically returned after the five year
uh five year jump when he was dusted
that it wasn't wong and steven strange
who were sharing the title of the
sorcerer supreme that it was wong who
maintained that role but that's one of
the issues that you run into at the
living tribunal is a lot of times its
intervention is arbitrary it's random
that there are times when the living
tribunal should step in but because of
how the writer in marvel comics is
telling the story the living tribunal
doesn't and it just it's really really
inconsistent in that way having said
that as far as the mcu is concerned the
living tribunal potentially appearing
here brings in a whole host of different
things the far shore the dimension of
manifestations all that kind of stuff
now we probably won't see all of that
certainly not in doctor strange too but
i would go as far as to say that if the
living tribunal does appear and it has
any measure of a meaningful role then
it'll basically be putting doctor
strange and the scarlet witch on trial
right so the idea here is that the
scarlet witch at least according to the
rumors and everything is leading her
universe or potentially sending her
astral form outside of her universe into
other universes in order to find a
universe where her kids exist and then
presumably bring her kids into the main
marvel cinematic universe and have her
kids there that violates the laws that
the the timeline right the way in which
the universe worked kind of the idea of
the sacred timeline from loki that the
way it worked is that wanda basically
had a chance to have her kids that she
basically created them during the events
of one division her kids weren't real
she lost them that was her role as much
as it sucks that's the lot that she drew
in life that's part of her plan and that
as a result of that if she basically
deviates from that violates it and then
goes into the multiverse and starts
snatching up other versions of her kids
the tribunal would step in and say no
that's not what you're supposed to be
doing now you could also look at
somebody like america chavez and say
okay if what we're talking about here
are people who are basically flouting
the rules of the multiverse by just
jumping to different realities and doing
things wouldn't the living tribunal stop
america chavez from existing and the
answer is no because presumably the
powers that america chavez gained is the
power to jump from one universe to the
next it's natural it's just the nature
of her abilities she didn't gain them by
stealing the powers of an alternate
reality counterpart she didn't gain them
by somehow accessing a source of power
that didn't belong to her that that's
just the natural power she has i.e she's
supposed to be able to do that so
there's no reason for the living
tribunal to step in but again like the
tribunal basically if this were to
happen what you would most likely see
here is the tribunal would grab wanda
and it would grab steven strange and it
would basically bring them to either the
far shore or the dimension of
manifestations now the way these two
things work is the far shore is
basically beyond all existence and so
there have been precious few people who
have actually experienced it who have
been there thanos is one of the people
who have the reason why it happened with
thanos is because during secret wars in
2015 thanos was killed by doctor doom
the problem with this is thanos had
previously been banished from the realm
of mistress death she was the only
cosmic her and oblivion i think we're
the only cosmic entities to survive the
collapse of the multiverse because if
anything dies it goes to the realm of
mistress death therefore she represents
death she can't actually die unless she
did during the cancer of her storyline
and thanos imperative but the important
thing about this is that she basically
survived but she had banished thanos
from her realm which meant that when
thanos was quote unquote killed by dr
doom he was transported to the far shore
a place outside of all time and space
the first universe was banished there at
one point along the line and then
usually what happens is whenever the the
congressional or the cosmic congress
meets so the cosmic entities of any one
universe or what have you whenever they
meet to basically
talk with a living tribunal it's at the
far shore the other exception to that is
the dimension of manifestations so the
dimension of manifestations was a place
that was established in the old quasar
comics from back in 1992 and the idea
behind this is that because cosmic
entities are abstracts they don't have a
physical form that cosmic entities can't
readily appear with a physical form so
what they do is they go to the dimension
of manifestations they meet with a being
called anthropomorpho that gives them a
physical body and that using that
physical body then they reappear in
their own universe presumably the living
tribunal is beyond this i don't really
know it's just the explanation marvel
gives us right just roll with it right i
mean does it make perfect sense no but
it's also comics who cares but that's
that's kind of how these things work
this is a this is a circumstance where
the living tribunal would most likely
appear that basically it would show up
and it would say no like wanda you have
to stop what you're doing or i will
annihilate you i wouldn't be surprised
if that happened that you would see
wanda almost kind of play out this adam
warlock roll from the events of of
infinity war when adam warlock got the
infinity gauntlet and they tried to take
it away and he freaked out and tried to
attack everybody and the living tribunal
just shut down the infinity stones like
it would be that kind of a thing with
wanda that she might even try to attack
the living tribunal in which case if the
living tribunal is in is feeling some
type of way it would just obliterate her
from existence but in reality it'll
probably just shut her powers off same
thing with doctor strange that kind of a
thing again i don't know if this will
happen that's a that's an awfully big
thing to cram into a movie that's only
supposed to be about two hours long so i
don't necessarily know if that'll be the
case the reality here is if the living
tribunal actually appears in doctor
strange two it'll have a brief cameo
it'll have either a really really small
moment that's only a couple minutes long
or we'll simply just see it observing
things and that'll be it right we won't
really see any intervention with a
living tribunal because the truth about
this is we don't know what its role and
its purpose is if you follow the marvel
comics logic it makes no sense for the
living tribunal to exist at all because
there have been a multitude of
circumstances where the living tribunal
could have stepped in like literally the
entire climax of what if when ultron had
the infinity stones and somehow managed
to use the infinity stones to like
travel through different realities and
so on and so forth while fighting the
watcher that would have been a time for
the living tribunal to step in like the
reformation of the multiverse at the end
of loki it would have made sense for the
living tribunal to step in then or at
least to appear so we don't really know
what its role is we don't know what its
form and function is we simply know that
presumably it exists because of what we
saw in the tv spot for doctor strange
too either way i'm excited man because i
love the living tribunal oh god it's so
phenomenal if you guys do want to see
the story where the living tribunal dies
i'll also have that link in the
description as well to comments explain
the video series on jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers phenomenal story
make sure you guys check it out it's
absolutely nuts but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
and i will catch you all later
peace